hey there I know you don't want to see
me yet so before we get to the intro I
want to thank you all for your
overwhelming support especially these
last few months some of you been asking
about your mugs okay I want you know the
vendor expects all mug Club orders that
have been placed before August 26th to
go out this week all of the remaining
orders they should be going out by
October 9th so hold me to that I really
hope we meet it we just had a ton of
orders and since these are hand-painted
Hanoch I know some of you been waiting a
long time I really appreciate it and for
those of you who would not have not yet
joined up at mug Club lot of credit calm
slash mug Club we need you more than
ever I think you can see this right in
this recent data that came out from
YouTube we have been most affected by
the reason algorithm look at that more
than al Jazeera will talk about it more
there's some stuff behind the scenes
that I can't necessarily talk about
final note the Halloween spooktacular
for those who don't yet know it's
October 31st at Texas A&M University the
tickets are going fast but there is
going to be an overflow room with Penn
telus half-asian bill Richman will be
there an after-party bring your mugs
bring your costumes and we're gonna have
some giveaways again go to lotta with
credit calm / tour we really appreciate
the support enjoy the show lahter with
crowder studios protected exclusively by
walter and hopper
now throughout my news have come to
realize there are seven words you cannot
ever ever say on YouTube now no one ever
tells you what these words are you have
to say them out loud for YouTube to
cancel you because it's YouTube's
ever-changing list same words two years
later a different list and these words
[ __ ] cheek [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and
Mexican yesterday those are the world's
retort [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] fig
and Mexican and Mexican doesn't even
belong on that list it's a benign word a
descriptor really how else do we refer
to them sir he's one of those members
from down south Honduran ha no
Salvadorian no Colombian Argentinian
Peruvian Chilean Brazilian he's Mexican
cancelled just like that
these words reach our [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] fig and Mexican now the
problem with these words is that words
change notice I didn't say the n-word
why because everyone who knows which
word that is not one member in the
audience right now is thinking no bye no
because the n-word has only ever been
one word with one meaning but not [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] vague and
Mexican every one of those cancel worthy
words in today's culture which we can't
say now at some point meant something
else [ __ ] would let you scary cancel
were they word for today's backyard
mechanic
well your starters fine your alternator
works but there seems to be a leak in
your tea world mainly the t-word gasket
where it's dick used to be cheap now
granted that would seem self-explanatory
until you realize again that it's a word
with multiple meanings captain I found
the c-word in their armor
no not [ __ ] I wouldn't find that mid
armor less I suppose she's a female
Knight but then we'd have to add another
word to the list see because these words
they also change depending who's using
them or who is hearing them they can't
just hurt on their own they're just
words but you can use that c-word on
youtube you can use that c-word provided
that it's not the previously
aforementioned c-word and that said
person using this given c-word is a
woman and that they're referring to the
current president's wife you see words
change Cinque was a common word a benign
word it was used in cultural idioms to
make it a hate word because a jackass
said something racist is to give that
racist power and it convolute s' the
meaning of the word now you have people
who mistakenly believe it to be the
original meaning of that word captain we
found a chinese-american in their Armour
do you that that's the sound of a
protest starting now please note that
the asian-americans themselves are
always notably absent from these
protests till let the other social
justice warriors distract you well they
simply take over your economy and
skilled labor employment opportunities
they don't make protest signs they're
too busy making money seems they found
your them in your armor [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] fig and Mexican now
[ __ ] or [ __ ] these are the new F words
if you say those you're immediately
canceled on YouTube primarily because
it's moderated entirely by F words
no not [ __ ] that's the old F word you
can say [ __ ] all you want on YouTube
provided that it is not referring to in
a derogatory manner the performative
actions of in a for mentioned f-word and
here we run into another problem because
these words they were co-opted these F
words - they - throughout history have
had different meanings to different
people's a [ __ ] a [ __ ] well are we
talking about a bundle of sticks a lazy
old lady or George Michael in a
California rest stop I was performing in
London a man outside the venue asked for
a cigarette he was put before a Human
Rights Tribunal Your Honor my client
merely asked the man in question for an
F word do you mean to say that your
client was soliciting prostitution no
your honor he just wanted a cigarette
he's not an F word
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I was doing the peck dance until I
realize that a black shirt is horrible
for the confident can see what was the
move on anything else there was a film
with her twin babysitter's who were
black-haired bodybuilders with the kid
from three nails party no you're making
Hajj cultural differences I'll be okay
if Gerald says something else so I will
shove bamboo wood chips up your stumps
okay listen Eric Cocker does on the show
you might be saying hey who's that he is
the whistleblower who product very tusks
came out from Pinterest and he has some
more info on some of the the new big
tech issues going on question is who do
you think is the most dishonest Democrat
in office at present you know what it
can be media personalities but let's go
with politicians pretty is it
congressman Schiff how do you way you'll
like this because he's all into fiction
no because effectively said look I only
read fiction I only read the books I
don't see the movies this is called
foreshadowing we talking about Congress
do you think it's congressman Schiff or
can you come up with someone else who
lies more more blatantly publicly
repeatedly we have my half-asian lawyer
bill Richman is here thank you sir for
being here quarterblack capture me hood
pass and G Morgan Jr he's tapering off
painkillers with wine of the day that's
tough coming down from that shed to say
Michelle artist series now it's
fantastic speaking of calm downs I meant
you I'm not even sure we did a lot to
get to but but first here's uh
sleeveless lesbian getting a flu shot
well there you go
[Laughter]
shoo Bueller NATO he skateboard it in
there - orange juice or cookies no I'm
just full of energy on my own you see
yang showing him up know what add yank
it and the same thing stuck the needle
in his neck and then raise more cash
than God encountered it really quickly
you know what I'm talking about me
talking about shift it's a slow news
week outside of Ukraine and let's be
honest we don't have any more info than
you do so I don't care that much
important story Hillary Clinton said in
an interview recently that Donald Trump
knows he's quote an illegitimate
president so if she says it this comes
from HuffPo you know it's trustworthy
she went on to add that his guilty
conscience over being illegitimate was
the main reason he is so obsessed with
her Makena might Democrats have been
pushing this idea of Trump not being a
legitimate president you know this is
the first time they've been trying to
completely undermine the office that I
flow my life and I know he lost the
popular vote but he won well over the
270 electoral college votes needed to
win as far as him being obsessed with
Hillary Clinton okay she may have a
point he doesn't want to work and
anything processed or sold or sell
anything that's been bought sold it
processed that stuff don't even watch
say anything No okay I'm not so much a
John Cusack fan but I am a Joan Cusack
aficionado
king of ours you stop it no just because
she's not traditionally beautiful at all
truth is my traditional I mean beautiful
speaking of our president a new book
came out he's never gonna come on the
ship claims like her he wanted a border
wall stocked with quote snakes and
alligators comes from the book quotes an
anonymous source who explained that
Donald Trump wanted a reinforced border
wall the wall would include barbed wire
snakes and alligators to dissuade the
Mexicans from illegally crossing the
border as well as a water filled moat to
stop the blacks also in the news Robert
DeNiro they have trouble swimming oh
yeah
Asian bill Richman you guys you guys
don't need to learn how to swim you're
so so buoyant you're like the baby on
the Nirvana cover no it's higher
thinking I really I really Drive are but
I know the feeling also in the news
Robert DeNiro appeared on CNN's reliable
sources I hate using that name Brian
Stein his show yeah and for those who
missed it this is how it went down a lot
of you okay well you know this is Kerry
so it's not still a Sunday morning yeah
what's the point there's that people are
in church and so Sunday mornings not
when you say that I don't know that's
Sunday more I think I'm in Sunday
mornings we're busy at the local
porta-potties it's it's listen it's
Robert De Niro okay when you have Robert
in your on your show you should expect
Robert De Niro yeah and people don't
know this I didn't see the interview
only got worse but it is still a Sunday
morning let's put in a break sorry I'm
sorry
oh it's a family show okay not now I
know okay go take a SoulCycle you're fat
let's squeeze in a commercial umpty
Dumpty put this fat back together you
know you should have expected that I
zero parts suppressions is zero part
surprise and nine parts not surprised
one part of joyous exactly at least he
called them out we're switching the
science because we talk about science on
this show
they're now claiming that when they told
people eating less red meat was a good
idea may have been horrible yes this
comes from New York Times the new report
claims there's no evidence to support
the belief that eating less pork and
beef is healthier for while critics
claim this research quote erodes public
trust in the scientific community this
is coming of course from the vegan
lobbyists people who don't like hearing
this is the scientific community by the
way is at odds over this new info with
staunch advocates right now arguing
vigorously from both sides to defend
their position but if red meat were
driving cancer and you reduced red meat
and you see no effect on cancer that is
a pretty strong indication that red meat
does not cause cancer I'm convinced
absolutely I'm thrilled about this right
because they think that we don't trust
them already and it's because they do
stuff like this they're oh I don't ever
throw that Greta clearly slam-dunked
that debate
Greta was excellent just a 10 out of 10
yeah she was she was on her a-game I was
bypassing Greta hiring her at the law
firm it's done it offers exchange she
was bringing the heat unlike Rudy at
Notre Dame 2012 the biggest argument
pre-show we've ever gotten into because
of the hell buddies never gonna know
nobody except for the people we recorded
see that up there in Mudd Club for some
reasons yield supports the idea that
reapply even though we didn't get a
second and I had more okay stop it I
know you're killing off of Norco but
come on now it's difficult okay and 2020
news presidential candidate Kamala
Harris said this week that Twitter
should suspend president Trump's account
she said the privilege of using words in
that way should probably be taken from
him advice considering Kamala Harris has
a long and storied history of taking
people's rights away is it the
alligators no bigger get it miss Gerald
B Gerald B at least no like you know
what Gerald B would say you know I don't
have to get it maybe this one's not for
me he let it slide I'll go with it where
is this Jerry
no see in the audience who was laughing
until I said the one thing you didn't
like it no I'm not for this I didn't get
to Arnold Palmer's to hear you and so my
sweetheart silence because we're a very
cultured program here the art scene
someone but we're gonna be talking about
to shift in a little bit and of course
we're in cotton but this is this is
important the art scene this is what
shapes culture someone just bought a
painting of Channing Tatum's scrotum so
it's described as a very realistic
portrait Wow
the Hollywood Titan in it sold for over
six thousand dollars initial report
implied that it was actually nude
painting it turns out it was just a
picture of Tatum on the red carpet with
21 Jump Street co-star Jonah Hill so
yeah he still looks very much like Jonah
very much the roughneck
not poor got anything different than the
reality eat a point there Jumanji no I
look I'm a fan of art just like
everybody else but really like seriously
getting down to the person that spent
$6,000 on that like how how is that
something that you want to have that's
an idiot don't understand art
aficionados I usually see it that I'm a
fan of art like anybody else which means
I'm not a fan of arts pretty much this
Monet well probably just as much as the
next guy look at it it's been six shot a
scrotum out there dollars that brings us
right now actually to a new segment a
lot of Crowder's entertainment minute
now
[Music]
what was it that was needlessly long I
was half-expecting Mario Lopez to show
up I don't know why I don't think it's a
job anymore since he had the gall to
suggest that giving four-year-olds
puberty blockers might not be good
parenting sorry Mario just kidding we
don't I don't know what you can do other
than AC Slater and talk about things
that don't matter the van that's true
Metallica and entertainment is the bad
Metallica has canceled the upcoming tour
dates about this they canceled upcoming
tour dates Oh frontman James Hetfield
can spend some time in rehab and came
out he reportedly suffers from a
crippling addiction to making she music
yes you are a terrible person is great
that's the sound of Metallica album
sales plummeting doesn't understand that
he has the power to manipulate markets
he's like a wolf bill was there too
[Laughter]
actress Linda Porter after rob garrison
and restaurant to her Karl Ruiz I
believe isn't it they all died last week
so you know they say that celebrities
die in threes evidently the same goes
for people have never heard of legendary
singer Jose Jose that's that's his name
nothing like a walking stereotype Jose
Jose he died at age 71 and the cause of
death is listed as quote L heart attack
Oh finally singer Ricky Martin and
husband Juan Yosef are expecting their
fourth child together
horse yeah Ricky Martin says he
impregnated the surrogate by closing his
eyes and picturing a hot hairy ass
[Music]
you should have seen half asian
leftovers he made rodney dangerfield
eyes the last it was actually just
exactly like that that's actually a very
good I actually pulled my steam release
I would love to see an Asian Rodney
Dangerfield gain weight more weight or I
get to shift President Trump told the
press this week that the White House is
quote trying to find out who the
whistleblower is a lot people know that
some people of course reviewing this as
a thinly veiled threat against the
anonymous accuser a source in the White
House has actually said that the
president is heading up a new
investigation himself even going as far
as making some phone calls how much he
bought it for and if that whistle was
any time head ok frankly listen because
you're not listening you call yourself a
Salesman I have reason to believe you
sold a whistle
to someone with a strong intention
frankly to blow it huh was that
corruption it's the Internet all
language [ __ ] knows no boundaries hey
who was last week's trivia contest
winner there
you are Val ah
Norval aah ring they are a furry so oh
oh jeez Wow well that's perverse
answering that I painted Muhammad using
menstruation as Bob Ross so we're gonna
send a wonderful gift card nice alright
is everyone ready to move on to Adam
Schiff yes do it we'll talk a little bit
about the Ukraine you know we had a
segment yesterday on the Ukraine deal it
was all formatted and I appreciate you
giving me some time I just sort of rant
about why I think Donald Trump is the
right man for this job at this point in
time in fact we don't have a whole lot
more info than other people do but I
think at the blaze TV they're actually
doing a whole live show tonight lending
back right after this for those who are
watching on the blaze those watching on
YouTube you'll have to sign up covering
from pillar to post the Ukraine scandal
so let's focus on Adam Schiff he's in
the news for his involvement with the
scandal now here's the thing it turns
out for people who don't know that the
chief knew about the whistleblower
complaint before it was filed and his
team actually advised the whistleblower
on how to proceed and President Trump
this is why he's just the best president
ever I mean I mean he's kind of better
like if you put him like okay we're
gonna prank him above like missus won't
matter
no no George Washington is a distant
second he was asked about it responded
like this at a press conference
yesterday
there is a report that came out just
before you and president Initiative
walked out here that the whistleblower
met with should be it shows that and I
love that question thank you John
[Laughter]
Thank You Jenna thank you I love you
John this one would I say favorite I
mean not okay there's a solid response I
love it was just ready he was ready with
it as soon as the question is asked he
just like got it his paper like he has
the cheat sheet like the guy in white
squall who gets kicked off the boat
before the husband can reach his wife
it's very sad film good company good
time so here's a trump president rump is
right not only did shift secretly
communicate with the whistleblower he
lied about it which brings us to this
week's what a piece of shift took Howard
to change it over to shift its a whole
paradigm shift it's not a super long
clip but I think it provides context not
only did he communicate he lied about
the whistleblower in communicating with
him we have not spoken directly with the
whistleblower we would like to really
really mm-hmm
that's interesting guess it's more of a
glans penis at that point to pretend
with a mouse more the Clydesdale has a
Mane so shivered by the way here's
something important to note this is the
more you one peel the layers to this
onion the more enraged you will you will
find yourself yeah he was mirroring
actually the whistleblowers talking
points on Twitter over a month ago to
give a false sense of corroboration
right because people see it and go AHA
psyche well this sounds like what this
sounds like what that shift character
said keep in mind the whistleblower
doesn't any first-hand knowledge of the
event right there's it's just not
someone said that Donald Trump dance
something somebody said something then
he went to shift and shift turned around
and corroborated it preemptively what is
he corroborating the complaint didn't
have any there was no first-hand
knowledge of it in the first place
someone said nothing I'm gonna go on
Twitter and and I'm gonna lay the
foundation right that this happened that
someone said something and then you'll
come out and then I'll tell them that I
didn't talk with you about it also I
mean I might kill myself right hey Bill
a chance but by the way is first-hand
information important
illegal I mean only if you want to be
morally and justifiably right yeah sure
just if I'm not a lawyer
I don't depends what Mark you're trying
to hit they're like being on in a store
or [ __ ] bag I got just I feel as the
standard at the left are using legally
is is vini and my cousin Vinnie before
he improved before the redemptions
anything they thought they were getting
a can of tuna fish only that's what
they're doing and they think I don't win
this yeah this it's very clear that
they've his idea of how we're gonna go
but you know imagine he would have
gotten away with it right I mean if he
would have gone a little bit better he
could have gotten away with looking
prescient having found this information
and instead he's caught red-handed I can
do it to other she shot the clerk shift
shut the clerk so here's another example
if he claimed that Trump tried to get
dirt from the Ukraine on his political
opponents that's kind of at the crux of
this right well here's something else if
we're talking and I don't want to do
that what about ISM because I don't
think this is a what about ISM I don't
think there's a direct comparison I
think that what Schiff has done is far
far worse let me explain and a
videographic evidence take that Young
Turks just Google would you do it I
understand that the Young Turks Samantha
beat these people they don't even
provide sources that yeah Google isn't
that your I don't know Java yeah you
know thank you going to arrest not the
chicken cordon bleu gyro cooker
aljazeera money so Schiff himself tried
to get tried to procure I'm trying to
use more official term nude pictures of
President Trump from the Ukrainians but
here's the thing
the Ukrainians turned out to be Russian
pranksters they were comedians and they
they pulled the wool over his eyes
okay what's the nature of the compromise
well there were pictures of naked Trump
when they were in Ukraine we got their
conversation by the phone where they're
discussed those compromising materials
we are ready to provide it to FBI so we
will try to work with the FBI to figure
out along with their staff how we can
obtain copies of those of course we will
provide you all our cookies of all our
materials okay first off I guess we'll
just ignore the raging homoerotic
undertones right yeah
you come after venture Pierrot because
they said no what no one has described
Brett Kavanaugh as penis which is kind
of a trend now with rapist and happen
with Michael Jackson happen to Bill
Cosby right there did you hear [ __ ] well
can you send me can you send me the
photo negatives I got a I got a presence
me when I would try and scramble the
satellite signal when I was a kid and I
couldn't actually afford it to my
parents room the next room it is amazing
to me he was trying to find my nudists
pictures and by the way nude pictures
that's not even a scandal it's just
embarrassing especially with this
president do you think he would actually
care he's like that's the best body come
on look at that he would turn it on by
the way it's a notification bail join my
club if you have an already $99 any one
six nine four students Federer Nats of
active military and just check the page
we do a new segment every single day
because as you've seen will be easier if
I were a pimp yes they're on the
recommended feed yeah trending at the
top may be backhanding shift here's
another example here why I think he's
absolutely just a stunning I mean it's a
skill as to how pieceof should be he is
I remember when that the text of the FBI
agents was a page and Stroke they were
releasing yeah yeah okay so we direct
evidence of FBI agents saying that they
wouldn't let Trump get elected because
they had quote insurance policies in
case he did all right Gary responded
that the FBI heavily favored Trump over
Clinton here you go
they were very selective in what they
released there were multiple reports
last year that the FBI was heavily
predisposed against Hillary Clinton and
in favor of Donald Trump you know he's
not necessarily wrong depending on who's
working there at the end yeah I think we
all assume there can be biased because
people human beings have biases right
right sure
but when Trump does that when he's uh
Kobe's a hacker Muller listed this is a
witch-hunt they try to accuse him of
obstruction yeah for doing exactly what
Schiff is doing there
yeah exactly well and he has he has big
trust issues with the establishment
around him and you wonder why when stuff
like that comes out in FBI agents say
things like that that's not just a
casual text right that's not just casual
conversation of course he's not gonna
trust and those are the people in charge
of investigating are you kidding me you
wouldn't trust people like that so of
course you would go out and say these
things and try to defend yourself in the
press I wouldn't trust Schiff find a way
another example he's known this is
something people know he's known it's
kind of his his rays own dad for leaking
repeatedly private info to the press and
then lying about it
CNN is running quotes from noon on about
my testimony
you know testimonies to bodis what's
going on in there since he's never met a
camera he didn't love I would bet a lot
of money that it was him are you heard
though but you got the point you want to
respond are you sure he you know he's
been making this claim all along just to
be precise yes or no did you leak any of
the information from his testimony no I
don't leak well beg to differ how do you
get caught flat-footed by Wolf's lowest
score ever on celebrity jeopardy Blitzer
with this specific clip maybe we cannot
prove that he's lying he's gonna say
trust me and here's something else I
would love to I defer to a half-asian
Larry bill Richman listen Jeff during
the mauler Investigation shift he
repeatedly claimed that he had seen
beyond circumstantial evidence that
Trump had colluded with Russia
even after Mahler ruled that there was
no evidence of collusion people say if
the report didn't say no collusion well
not a second it just says there's no
evidence of it you can say that about
anything someone who gets off for any
crime well the fact that he wasn't
convicted of shoplifting doesn't mean
do it but there's no evidence so he's
not guilty of it that's how society
works correct absolutely we have a legal
system and if there is no evidence and
you are not convicted it means you
didn't commit the crime in the eyes of
the law right that's exactly that's what
that's exactly why we have the system is
to be able to call balls and strikes
make it don't make it done and then move
along and here what I find hilarious is
the example that he has beyond
circumstantial evidence it's like it's
like the beyond meet impossible burger
right it's like no it's not and this is
not actually evidence right you actually
have to have something and when he's
asked repeatedly and repeatedly
repeatedly he dances around well we
didn't actually talk to him and well we
didn't actually get direct evidence but
like we put if you put together the
different inferences and lies then it's
a story yes if you put enough here's
what's important if you put together
different inferences accusations and of
course keeping in the front of your mind
at all times that I am a piece of [ __ ]
but I think you will come to see this
issue in a new light here's actually a
clip of him doing just that all you have
right now is a circumstantial case
actually no Chuck I can tell you that
the case is more than that and also go
into the particulars course ignore than
circumstantial evidence now so again I
think do you have seen direct evidence
of collusion I don't want to go into
specifics that is not circumstantial as
I've said along there's plenty of
evidence of collusion and corrupt
commingling of work between the Trump
campaign and the Russians good lord I
mean by the way unless you think we're
editing him out of context
he never did provide specific you and
you're waiting for it don't hold your
breath yeah
google it what does it mean when he's
saying more than circumstantial explain
people who don't know what
circumstantial evidence means we throw
that around a lot so indirect evidence I
mean circumstantial evidence can be
things that create an inference of what
the actual thing may be now so for
example if you have you know you want to
say someone committed fraud you'd be
able to prove fraud you have to prove
that they intended to deceive you and a
lot of the times you can't read
someone's mind and unless they say I
intended to defraud you you that would
be direct evidence you have
circumstantial evidence like they knew
the truth but they told you a false
statement anyways here when you say you
have circumstantial evidence you should
be able to describe that circumstantial
evidence it
you have beyond circumstantial evidence
you definitely can explain what it is
but yet when he was asked you have
direct evidence which is the only thing
beyond circumstantial evidence is there
there's no in-between there's like
circumstantial middle stanshall piece of
shift stanshall i mean that is yeah
there is shift stanshall but that's like
somehow hitting two keys on a piano at
the same time and getting a note in
between that's nobody's note I mean it's
there it's not the thing it's not it's
not there nothing like perpetuating the
original I think I think we're gonna
look back on this is one of the worst
political like hatchet jobs in United
States you Chinese but I really do I
think we will I think we'll look back on
this and go oh my gosh when people came
out and said that I don't think Donald
Trump is going to accept the election
results right the Democrats said that
and then it goes against them and now
they're thinking oh no it's Russia Clues
we've got to throw everything at him I'm
serious like this is this is bad for the
country doesn't matter what side you are
on because now we have the next person
doing the exact same thing so what
happens when the next person gets in the
office it's a liberal or Democrat you
think some Republicans wouldn't do that
somebody wouldn't say well you did it
wrong - hey man Jill him just keeps
swinging further and further so you have
to calm this credit I mean I don't see
any Republicans and I do I really either
Lindsey Graham I mean he's kind of he's
kind of slimy he's a little bit greasy
there's that she beat I don't think the
Republicans would step to that quickly
but if you open the door to it you can
take a president out bite on it I've
grown I've grown tired of your
commentary because this waiting for a
lot of people haven't seen this it only
trended in two hours on Twitter and it
was gone and that it was gone in my
opinion as bad as it gets
it's as bad as anything I've ever seen
in the political arena when people talk
about the right and the left are
dividing us I got no no no hall second
let's not do the equivalency here
because have you seems pretty shift he
made us an entire dialogue of trumps
phone call with the Ukrainian president
I want you to see him doing this here
presenting this as though it was fact he
expresses his interest in meeting with
the President and says his country wants
to acquire more web
from us to defend itself and what is the
president's response well it reads like
a classic organized crime shakedown I
hear what you want I have a favor I
won't mind you none of us have and I'm
gonna say this only seven times so you
better listen good I want you to make up
dirt on my political opponent understand
lots of it now I know some of you're
asking because I get it it's it's
difficult today and our polarized
society to know ok who's exaggerating
where are you stretching because
everyone does especially for comedy we
do that yeah so you're wondering how
much what percentage of that if we were
to put a number on it is is accurate
zero nothing nothing no no none of that
ever happened and here's something
that's so dishonest to when you watch it
he he's reading it and at one point he
looks up and looks back down and goes uh
though as though he missed a word it
he's reading for an official transcript
he met he tried to clearly imply that
this was an official transcript and then
when he was called on it this was his
response that it was parody my summary
of the president's call was meant to be
at least part in parody you know when
Donald Trump talked about people got all
upset because he would talk about
changing libel laws right and this was
really just to try and get media stand
now we weren't happy about it how is
that not slander right yeah he read it
as though with the transcript he tried
to hit a high micing of people didn't
understand it's parody that's a whole
new problem implying like because Donald
Trump's is such crazy stuff that you
thought it was real when I made up stuff
that Donald Trump said that was crazy
that never really happened but I told
you he said crazy stuff and so you tend
to believe that this crazy stuff is
crazy stuff he would say but I'm just a
piece of [ __ ] you gotta give him credit
though for how well he sells the reading
act right you know the looking down the
pauses the keeping it going I mean for
if for anyone I mean the first time I
saw that clip I thought to myself I'm
gonna google it and look and you go look
it up and you're like wait I don't
actually see any any of these words I'm
not lying
no no no well wait I did see two of them
there was two thousand there that he
asked yes yes there were thoughts there
was also a
similar number of vowels from just long
as a piece of it wasn't enclosed he
didn't even stumbled across truth
accidentally it is remarkable to me that
this was allowed to go this is I think
that is worthy of being forcibly removed
from office
I really do to me that's just a
pertinent I don't mean violently no I
mean this guy should be forced to resign
in absolute shame I can't think of
anything that would personify fake news
more than reading from a fake transcript
and by the way the reason he's doing
that is because he knows that most
people who are not hyper ly engaged
unlooked at people in this room or often
people who are watching this show or
reading in the comment section he knows
are gonna walk by the TV screen see this
and go oh my god I can't believe our
president did that right I can't believe
he said that and they're not going to
see the aside where he says it was
clearly a parody just like you don't see
the slander you don't see the libel you
do see it sir that occurs on the front
page and then the apology the retraction
is issued two weeks later on page eight
yeah he knew exactly what he was doing
and by the way just to go into Ukraine
thing a little bit Democrats they've
repeatedly reached out to foreign
countries including the Ukraine for dirt
on Trump okay so at worse at the
absolute worst schiff is just accusing
Trump of what he has done himself only
Donald Trump hasn't done it his
accusations are false the favor that
Trump asked for was investigating
foreign meddling in a u.s. election
specifically in regards there's a
company called CrowdStrike
not Biden as Schiff was trying I don't
want to say shift suggests right now
suggesting it's it's direct statement
yeah
what shifts saying is actually true it
wasn't that Schiff suggested that these
things were happening
he made Express statements intended to
deceive the public about what was said
that is fraud right there that's what it
is it's not yeah it's not what he said
happened isn't true but it is true that
shift it's like the inception of [ __ ]
yeah exactly and by the way I thought we
cared a whole hell of a lot about fair
elections Russian meddling in our
elections we have to get to the bottom
of that that was the entire thing we
heard from day one of his campaign now
he asks about it happening in Ukraine
right and we're like oh you can't ask
for that right and to be fair later on
in the call it was mentioned that you
know Biden shut down this prosecutor
investigation of it yes is a Sun year
before it was it was a minor point
here's what is pretty important to me to
ship in the whistleblower who I only got
no first-hand knowledge would that be
considered circumstantial not having
first hand yeah I mean it depends but
mostly that's considered circumstantial
because if you don't I mean there's
rules here say there's a reason why you
don't deck out-of-court statements and
use them for the truth because yeah you
can't actually test the boundaries of
what's true or not true I heard XYZ say
this fact and we're gonna take that fact
is true right how are you gonna test it
right now and eyewitness testimony isn't
considered verifiable proof so someone's
saying I heard someone say that Donald
Trump did this would seem to me I don't
know I'm a simpleton even less reliable
well I mean we at some point you have to
accept the accept evidence right so
right if you were to say okay hey look
at this piece of paper is the piece of
paper fake well you have to go through
certain standards to be able to get even
written evidence in so written evidence
is only as verifiable as any other piece
of evidence but the further you get away
from something be able to be verifiably
true in it's a spectrum the more likely
it is that you would never even be able
to use it in court and saying I heard
someone else say some other fact that
they observed but no one else saw we
have no other preparation is aligned too
far for every Western civilization so
yes thank God and here's something that
I think is important right there there's
a lot that we don't know and that's why
we try not to just offer nothing more
than than conjecture because maybe some
more info could come out you know the
people who stand firm in their opinions
when there's not enough info sometimes
they don't really age very well but I do
think it's important to look at what we
do know and compare it with what they've
said that is verifiably false right for
example we know for sure that that was
not a transcript and then he said it was
parody we know for sure that shift said
Donald Trump was withholding military
aid unless they and unless they
investigated that or sorry fired the
prosecutor that's what they said but
here's if you understand it Trump never
threatened that at all that it was even
mentioned the Ukraine officials did not
know about the change in military
foreign aid until a month after the call
yeah so you can't know everything but
you can know what they've said that is
false and you can know certain facets of
the story that are true
the things that we know to be true
they've already proactively lied about
right that's important for people to
think of that's important for people to
point out and I don't want to get into
the minutiae of it because like I said
Glenn Beck has a special to plays TV
whole thing about the Ukraine live after
this there's anything else you guys want
to say about you don't think it's to me
they know exactly what they're doing I
don't want to ascribe ulterior motives
we've always tried to do that on the
show yeah or if we do change my mind or
when we actually have debates that we've
had in the show with with politicians
with professors you know with people who
are who are worthy adversaries I always
try to assume that they are being
sincere but this is a rat this is an
exception it's I don't even wanna say
it's a radical exception he went up
there and lied and read it from a
transcript that didn't exist and when he
and what he was called on it said well
you know what that was meant to be
parody but what did you think it was
well you know what I think most people
thought it was what you intended it to
be which was a lie that you wanted to be
accepted wholesale as truth I don't I
didn't say this with Hillary clip you
like and she needs to be put in jail I
never jumped on that train
I don't like Nancy Pelosi it's crazy to
me that she's a reasonable one in the
party we have 20 of AOC Schiff Bernie
Sanders Pelosi you know she is she the
turkey she's terrible
well look you know put yourself in a
coma fended sir it's interesting to
think of what would be the rules if you
imagine a Republican had made up a
transcript yeah imagine if the
conservative had gone up there and said
oh well actually I'm just gonna go ahead
and fake this evidence because
apparently this is a House of
Representatives it's the Laugh Factory
that's the thing we do these hearings
yeah there's there's room for funny
questions and jokes there's no room for
faking evidence and at the very least
the house needs to consider or the
Senate or or you know whoever has the
ability to do that whether within the
party or outside the party to censure
that kind of behavior just saying you
don't agree with faking evidence and if
you want to come out and say something
to do something right to restore trust
in our system its police your own and
this is an example where the Democrats
need to put their money where their
mouth is I fancy could yeah so they want
to put our money where their mouth
necessarily but put yourself on a jury
hearing some of this stuff and shift
gets up on the stand and they play that
and they're attacking like he has no
credibility left they play stuff like
that they play the things that we've
played the clips where he's obviously
been lying the things where he's trying
to get new people don't know like no I
know problem put that put that up there
and then put the evidence that you have
it is it is a blow out there is no court
in America that would believe him and
not believe the evidence and yet in
public opinion he's still out there
saying this doctor if Donald Trump went
upright libertine about what would
happen a Republican did it okay let's do
this little walk it through this
exercise here and here I have Peter
Schiff mirroring what the whistleblower
was going to say abut for them odd
Twitter even though there was no
first-hand knowledge and shift no there
was no first-hand knowledge he said he
was going to go out and lie and
fabricate a transcript for the world to
see they were saying can you believe
this president is lying he's been
removed from office only he'd be telling
the truth yeah exactly yeah that was
video evidence that is how insane this
has become it's not what about ISM it is
far worse ISM as it relates to piece of
sh if Adam Schiff and actually we have
to get going to Eric Cochran
whistleblower from big tech but we're
actually getting word apparently the
altercation continues at CNN
in your mind let us begin our quest to
find your face I stopped you down your
face stupid join mug club where all our
musical parodies will be as bad as
president Trump's this is a direct
threat what's your home defense plan
when it comes to safety there's no
substitute for a quality firearm and if
you're a gun owner there's no
replacement for firearms legal
protection firearms legal protection
provides lawful gun owners an uncapped
legal defense program 24/7 emergency
hotline access to a network of over
2,500 experienced attorneys legal
education on firearm laws in your state
via our mobile app and plans to protect
you every step of the way if you are
involved in a self-defense
visit firearms legal comm /lw see today
I own the peoples of States unite I'm
here today and they the climate change
keep that garden in the south that's it
you were knocking at the gates of Hell
my friends I am an 18 year old
transsexual male female - ma'am well I
appreciate you clarify that because I
would have been horribly confused so a
boy is at his house he's taking a nap
and he's awakened by some sounds from
the room next door when I see people
were you know it's fourth of July black
American flags and then without fail if
they're a rainbow flag there was no
American flag right it's a one second
you can you do my love your country and
suck like you can be in my boat and all
of my latest videos come up in a youtube
search for my name the that's how I'm
looking for Paul Joseph Watson did you
mean to say Senor wences
[Music]
is he sang Zul yeah like like the like
the god yeah are you the keymaster
resigned the keymaster you the
gatekeeper
I don't know but you'll Rick Moranis
completely retired from the industry the
audio wait a missus I don't know did his
wife pass was that I think he took time
to take care of his kids to take care of
his kid was well that's far less
sinister yeah that's great dude I should
have led with that alright our next
guest very glad to have him on the show
now some of you may be saying oh I know
the name but if I'm not mistaken when he
first was revealed publicly it was in
that sort of Dateline blurred food
convoys you know usually to rapist but
he's not you can still he set some
context here he was he's a former
software engineering he was a
whistleblower came before with big tech
which is very relevant to what we're
doing by the way people who are out
there who have some tips very toss tips
at protonmail dot-com is what this
gentleman wanted us to uh to feed you
because they're always looking for new
info mr. Eric Cochran how are you sir
I'm doing well thank you for having me
I am glad to have you and I was just
saying you have those giant headphones
that you look like the the the VR kid
from Burger King kids club club I don't
remember this commercial it was a series
of commercial at the Burger King kids
club it's cool to be a kid and there was
a black guy with the house party hey
let's get the high-top the generically
lesbian girl there's the ginger there
was the wheel yes the wheel chair and
the white kid because they couldn't just
say here's a token white kid he was the
tech kid walkman Jeffrey yeah and Eric
you are very white so it suits you
perfectly
so listen for people who may not be
necessarily super familiar with you
because you weren't really like a
personality who spoke on politics or
culture you came into this specifically
because of some information that you had
in the big tech industry I don't want a
big tech I think we've trademarked that
so explain the people kind of your
history how you came to project very
does yes so just a few months ago I was
just a software engineer at Pinterest
and
and just kind of you know working on
Android apps actually and not not too
involved in politics and then I I was
seeing more and more censorship we were
talking about misinformation and hate
speech and and then it got to be much
more sinister I would see they actually
banned live-action secretly on the back
end the pro-life group Zero Hedge pj
media they were banning things about ben
shapiro bible verses and this was all
done in secret so i actually took this
to project Veritas james o'keefe
organization and and i said the public
has to know this like this is this is
the proof that we're kind of seeing from
the outside from these big tax companies
and now here's actually the how and the
why it's happening and nobody understand
why pinterest i mean i get like you know
google youtube at least and certainly
google at large facebook it's sort of
the information mainframe for politics
but pinterest i just sort of think of it
as those moms who drink too much or like
i'm having a one glass of wine for
dinner you know it's like a punch bowl
you know like like the old pogs the
classic pogs that's always why i
pictured pinterest why would they have
yeah i think you know that is it's a
really good point about like moms in the
middle of the country so it's
interesting that you know they're they
want to affect that market so much and
then what it really speaks to the
biggest point is that all the tech ends
up like this you know actually went to
pinterest because I thought it wasn't
Facebook it wasn't Google and and yet
once it got to be a big enough company
they're all they're on the same page
there's this whole hive mind a big tech
where these tech companies they're all
in Silicon Valley they all have the same
mindset they all want to you know effect
the 2020 election they want they there's
so much in an echo chamber they all are
on the same page about wanting to ban
Republican well now you said they want
to effect the 2020 election I get it for
example there's a big difference we need
to delineate here if they feel as though
all conservative speech is hate speech
you know using someone's biological
biologically proper pronouns if they
feel that that's hate speech I
understand how that could sort of
dictate their policies or behavior do
you think that's the case or you think
they are specifically setting out to
affect the 2020 election and if so what
makes you think the latter
well so I think there definitely is like
this this entire idea of like you know a
lot of conservative mainstream
conservative ideas are hate speech I can
speak like it Pinterest for the 2020
election it was interesting
there were these documents specifically
about protecting candidates like Kamala
Harris and Elizabeth Warren and bado
protecting them from basically memes and
on the imageboard
and they didn't have anything like that
for Republicans so it is interesting you
know I think it's again where they see
that they they think in their mind they
messed up in the 22:16 election they
messed up by allowing too much free
speech and then it let people get around
the media gatekeepers and so I think
really there is they think they're doing
the right thing they think that they're
they're protecting the public from these
ideas but ultimately it does affect the
2020 election so they're trying to
protect them from memes but how do they
protect Elizabeth Warren from herself
everything she uploads to Instagram like
I say have to watch at her my fingers
I'm just a little bit warm drinking up
here
here's like oh I want to shrink up into
my own body cavity and die like that
group of people in Superman too and
float off into space I don't know how
that's not really a question for you so
much you as a guest Eric I just I have
my own issues I'm working through
speaking of my own issues I don't know
if you've been following this but this
is another reason I want to have you one
you know we've experienced we've been
demonetized entirely on YouTube despite
Susan Wojcicki and YouTube admitting
that we haven't violated any policies
right this was kind of acquiescing to
the Vox ad pocalypse torch and
pitchforks mob but more recently and I
don't want to bore the the viewers here
because they know about this but I I
know that maybe you haven't been filled
in on all of it we found that we're
blacklisted shadow banned from specific
search terms so in other words a few
search steven crowder changed my mind
doesn't show up for many results if you
search steven crowder on youtube
business show up for 70 results and then
we found out and this is why i do think
there could be some meddling with the
20/20 election that if we used a VPN and
used an address up side of the United
States the UK or Sweden or Spain
that they showed up entirely it was only
blacklisted my name and our primary
videos or videos with the most place
blacklisted exclusively in the United
States we don't have any answers on that
yet from YouTube is that something that
surprises you do you have any answers
maybe can you help me help me yeah so
like we do know that you know there are
these they're these black lists inside
of inside of Google and so we can kind
of see the anecdotal evidence from you
know from the users side and like we saw
this a project Veritas to where a lot of
our videos you know just won't show up
you can see like CNN videos about
Project Veritas when you google when you
search on YouTube Project Veritas right
but um you know I think I think the
biggest thing people can do to help is
if you're on the inside of YouTube and
Google you know come to Project Veritas
Veritas tips at protonmail con again
like we see the evidence from the
outside I think now we need to see like
the how they're doing this from the
inside and you know is since the
Pinterest story we've actually had to
Google whistleblowers come out and and I
know like louder with Crowder was
actually on one of the Google now News
Feed blacklist that one of the insiders
exposed - yeah well I know why I mean
you know listen I'm sorry that you guys
are lumped in with this where we just
had Donald Trump playing Peter Gabriel
like you clearly are doing the Lord's
work and we just like dressing up like
ladies who let me ask you this
in your experience who would typically
order these kinds of black lists because
and this is just me sort of it's it's an
opinion it's speculation but it seems to
me that if it's blacklisted exclusively
in the United States someone had to do
that that's not an algorithm yeah right
so these these are typically manual
actions I mean again we don't know the
how in this case specifically but from
what we've seen historically they're
they're very manual operations and the
thing is you have about 90% of people in
tech companies are people like me or
like or at least people who just like
11:00 lit live and let live
they're not super political but then you
get like 10 percent of people who are
direct activists and they go in and they
and they advocate for adding people to
blacklist for censoring
people in certain regions and yeah I
mean a lot of there is a lot of
sophistication and being able to
delineate by region to in this case and
those people who say you know there's
there's 10% I think you said it might be
activists are they in a disproportional
amount of positions of power yeah so we
typically see this in like trust and
safety teams or some type of content
management teams right we're not talking
about the the software engineers the
people I guess like yeah like I used to
be right you know aren't typically
involved we're just trying to make good
software but you kind of have people in
these in these like misinformation
efforts who tend to be these these
complete like activists and who are
going to leadership and saying this this
stuff is hate speech we need to take
care of this and and then of course they
bow to the mob right I think
quarterblack Garrett had a quick one
Eric do you think it's possible that it
might be a single like bad actor that's
in there that just has the ability to
add these search results in there how
often are these things yeah or is it
more systemic yeah yeah I think that
sometimes the case but I'd say much more
much more often systemic I mean like at
Pinterest we were saying that where it's
really this entire team it you know in
these people again like are all in this
echo chamber they're all encouraging
each other and you know they a lot o
pretty much everybody thinks they're
doing the right thing they think that
you know they're very high IQ people and
people in the middle of the country just
don't know what to think and they need
to they need to take care of hate speech
and misinformation as they deem it so
final question before we go to the web
extended let me ask you this you said
that maybe 10% of people are activists
and I do think that people mean are is
Jack Dorsey Mark Zuckerberg Susan
Wojcicki are they all activists or is it
just because they tend to be liberal but
they're not activists do you think that
they're really sort of an empathetic ear
to these activists and the activists
know that they have a a quick path to
make getting these changes made and then
are there have you seen other employees
who might be leftist liberal in these
companies who knew what was going on and
thought that it was wrong regardless of
personal politics yeah
as for like the direct top leadership I
think a lot of them yeah
there there there left wing but again
there they're not complete activists
they just bow to the mob they just bow
to their employees who are activists who
are telling them we're gonna have walk
outs if this stuff doesn't stop and and
they're just kind of in a difficult
position in that way and then yeah I
think there definitely are like
left-leaning people inside these tech
companies I personally since my stories
come out and since the Google stories at
Project Veritas now have come out people
I used to people I used to work with in
the Android community are like I don't
agree with you on like the issues that
they were censoring pro-life
conservative issues but but I like I'm
totally against this tech censorship
right so they're totally I mean this is
also a free speech issue and I think
people were seeing that more and more so
I think that's a good point because a
lot of people think the First Amendment
only applies obviously to government
regulation of speech and it does but
there is a culture of censorship that
occurs right now I think people now call
it canceled culture but I think it goes
even further than that it goes further
than just celebrities and in comedians
getting protested when there is a
systemic blocking really a prevention of
people from even having a seat at the
table and here's somebody I said no I
said it was a last question I want to go
to Lubbock send it but you said they bow
to the mob this is something that's
important to me because a lot of people
on the Left you'll see the young turks
say this they say well a big day just go
where the money is but the truth is the
money isn't with the outraged mob most
people aren't on board with that so why
do you think it is that big tech
companies are willing to forgo some
profit in many instances to appease them
because that's that's a very new shift
for businesses I think it's true I think
that there are some things I mean
certainly to a lot of these like middle
manager or upper executives there are
things more important than money to them
you know they can always get a new job
they can they're already making lots of
money but they really view like their
mission as as you know directors for the
culture yeah makes sense it's
effectively practiced secularism as a
religion all right listen we're gonna go
to what extended but where is the best
place for people to send the tips
to get involved because we've had some
people send us stuff and we don't really
know what to do with it it's a comedy
show so where should people send it for
you yeah if you're on the inside of a
big tech company or any media
institution or you want to go undercover
with Project Veritas Project Veritas
comm slash brave send your tips to
Veritas tips at protonmail comm will
protect your anonymity and security they
will have you go undercover and you
don't even have to go in Trudeau
black-faced web extended for those who
are mug club will go to that for the
rest of you wait for the close I am only
interested in the individual purchased
and proceeded to frankly blow
[Music]
so here at this show we joke around
quite a bit because we like to have
enough name that reference for those who
don't I think you should know that one
but if you use your firearm in
self-defense for most people that's not
funny and most gun owners would never
actually think about what happens when
they've reached that point until it's
too late what do you say when the police
arrive more importantly what do you not
say you don't want to be on worldstar
that day can I say that why don't carry
already made it in that's where firearms
legal protection comes in there the
leader in prepaid self-defense
protection plans for your fire on
they're designed specifically to protect
you and your family and listen they have
the balls to support the show just like
Walter we are incredibly grateful and
they offer so much help to you and your
family from paying bills to bail bond to
helping you get your firearm back even
helping you get your home cleaned up
after you use it in your house in
self-defense so for some exclusive
pricing some discounts you can go to not
a lot of us credit I come and go to
firearms legal comm /lw see I'm so used
to plugging my own stuff because most
sponsors won't touch me thanks firearms
legal firearms legal comm /lw see I have
it everyone here has it it really is
worth doing for a nominal fee
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] called the sexy until he dies
churning dance but never and broke
character what is when did this become
sexy when was this the I don't know do
we know where that comes from is there
some historical context what is anyone
ever seeing this like a boo looks like
she is she is in heat understand it I
don't get it I'm gonna understand
breasts I understand naked people
but this hmm maybe she looks like a how
does it understand this I'm people like
this guy is hot and they do this has
anyone ever been sexually attracted to
and they actually get like temperatures
maybe it happened maybe that's may the
flushing that occurs during during
coitus women Rouge because it symbolizes
the flushing you so much air cochran web
extender what we get into some stuff
that we cannot talk about you two on
YouTube for those remote Club members
and for those who are not please do join
we're also going to have a whole episode
of jokes we cannot tell on YouTube next
week so soon a couple things I wanted to
talk about here and I know that
sometimes these are meant to be
inspirational and then I fail miserably
because I'm just in an angry place and
that happens but this this is about
thinking about today because I heard
this I don't know some self-help guru
was on the radio I'm lying not radio
some podcast was a commercial solutions
to radio anymore
nobody I feel like if if radio were a
book today you'd have to go like in the
pagemaster you know there's still people
there I don't understand I don't get it
but not ready was a podcast and you hear
that you know you hear this a lot you
we're always told to love ourselves love
yourself you're told to be kind to
yourself and I've heard that my whole
life I know you've heard that or some
iteration of that your whole life it
would always upset me and I guess in
part because I don't know what it means
or at least I don't know what it's meant
to convey or why it's something that
needs to play a role in our discourse I
don't think it's
let me premise this of course you should
appreciate your life and if of course
you should respect your body your mind
the blessings that have been bestowed
upon it your abilities and that means
taking care of them and I suppose that
means being kind to yourself I
understand that and yet yes okay your
life is a gift before I go negative here
and then I'm gonna turn it back around
so just just let this big tugboat get
pulled to shore it's gonna be up down
and then up again so yes your life is a
gift okay you should love it you should
love yourself and that's why I've talked
repeatedly about finding what it is at
which you are excellent what your
purpose is and creating a plan to
maximize your fullest capabilities and
as always that just it comes with making
a plan and repetitions repetitions
repetitions I've talked about that it's
getting the reps and getting the reps
and no one gets great at anything
without getting the reps and getting the
reps and even someone was a natural
talent it's about a plan discipline
repetitions go back to previous episodes
if you can search you can search them on
YouTube but you don't try and find them
some are you didn't find them on mug
club on theblaze and you'll see what I'm
talking about that is something I've
repeated ad nauseam maybe I'll put it in
a book someday I don't know you let me
know if you want a book probably not I
just don't want to write a book because
I don't use them I don't want you to
have to in three years do it this was a
best-seller back in the day and then I'm
dead from you know overdosing and
opiates because I got into Gerald stash
when he was tapering off I've never
touched him so let's replace the cocaine
rumor with hardcore heroin but I want to
I do I want to talk about something a
little less comfortable but equally
important today okay loving yourself
doesn't mean that you love everything
about yourself only a fool would feel
that way or maybe someone who's watched
too many romantic comedies and we see
this why can't he just love me exactly
the way I am well let me explain it
might be tough to but because a good
part of you there's a significant
portion of you that sucks
listen there are parts of yourself okay
that you should hate everyone out there
that's a good thing that's a good thing
there are parts of you you should hate
and I want to explore it a little bit
I use myself as an example first let me
plunge into this ice-cold pool so that
you don't feel so uncomfortable I don't
hate myself but there are things about
myself that I absolutely hate there are
aspects of my personality that I
recognize that I've worked on my whole
life and I despise I've talked about
this before being a game-day player
right nuts that's a good thing it's an
important quality to learn but it's not
a good quality to rely upon and about
this relating myself I hate that for
some reason I don't know why I've always
been this way there's a gear that I can
only kick into when things go badly when
the Vox ad pocalypse happened that's an
example recently there have been some
some pretty stressful situations that
have come up with YouTube more than that
but really that's that's been a big one
we're going back and forth with lawyers
it's been tough but I perform at my best
with my back against the wall I always
have I think it's why I've probably
procrastinated my whole life I was a guy
who'd cram for exams it's why I would
almost always wait until I found myself
in a position of conflict before really
sort of biting down on the mouthpiece
and getting to business it maybe just
goes to the ADHD personality I don't
know but it's not a good thing I hated
about myself I hate that most of the
time I feel tired I feel exhausted I
have trouble focusing and then for some
reason when something goes wrong some
high pressure situation arise I can for
some reason kick into a gear where it
almost feels as though I'm not me it
sometimes feels like I'm not even the
one speaking or acting but information
is travelling through me and I can't
control it
it only happens in positions of stress
which are not good for me my verbal
fluidity is an answer my short-term
memory locks on to where I need it to be
I'm focused on clear pain doesn't
register the same way I've literally
torn ligaments separated joints without
even realizing it until I driven home in
the adrenaline died down but here's the
thing being in that pressure cooker is
rare at least it should be and there are
only so many times you can redline that
engine and sometimes it's it's very hard
to fix and I haven't been able to fix it
you know I would I would love the effort
some people out there who are maybe
relating to this who struggle with this
if you have any solutions a part of me
talking about this is it's probably
looking for advice just as much as as
offering any
so please do comment uh the point is
this we're all told that you should love
yourself listen you should okay
but just like love the sinner hate the
sin it's okay I'm giving you permission
here it's okay for there to be things
that you don't like about yourself
you know why here's one because you're
not perfect the way you are that's a
very new concept by the way that you're
you're perfect just the way you are but
because pink wrote a song of it up until
very recently nearly all societies and
certainly all societies that I can think
of since modern Christendom started with
the baseline knowledge the acceptance of
the fact that you are imperfect we're
all imperfect but you specifically are
imperfect very much so and that the
pursuit of perfection is a facet of the
human condition but somewhere along the
way more recently as it relates to human
history maybe because it sells albums or
books I don't know we decided that it
was more important to convince people to
love themselves rather than to improve
themselves and here's my challenge to
you today don't think of all the things
you love about yourself we've done that
in the past and there's a time for that
I want you to think of the things that
you hate about yourself what is it
bothers you what is it that when you
look back on your life you're gonna say
or at least maybe you think you'll say
oh man you know I wish I didn't do it
that way I really wish I'd have taken
the time to fix that about myself I want
you to take a minute right now and
genuinely think about it think about
what that is then try to chart the
course to a solution and was this one
I'm facing I don't know for mine it's
tough I would advise you to start
searching I guess for for information on
on people who struggle with the problems
that are similar you know just like I've
talked about this in the past if you
want to get really good at something
start with trying to emulate the best in
the world it's something I don't
understand often you'll see people
interact let X your seat you'll see
people enter into any endeavor so well
I'm just gonna kind of work and see what
happens when all on a second if you
don't want to be the best at this you
have no business being in that arena
if you're going to emulate someone
emulate the best at it that's how that
should be your starting off point do the
same thing here with your struggles with
your
find someone who's had to overcome the
same hurdles someone who's who's driven
through the roadblocks someone who's
done it seek out an expert maybe it's a
medical professional I don't know maybe
it's a psychiatrist I have no idea in my
case you know listen it's difficult I
can't really search people who hit fifth
gear when they are under pressure and
feel chronically exhausted the rest of
the time it's the closest I can find is
adrenaline junkie some people have said
that that's what I am but I don't like
Heights so I think it's both but I don't
know but it's something that I don't
like about myself and something that
I've always had to work on and I think
if you listen to show you've heard me
talk about that before trying to find
that third gear I think for a long time
there were maybe three years doing this
job where I was working from 5:00 in the
morning to 7:00 at night every day every
day and then I worked like a basic eight
hours on Saturday and a few hours in
Sunday and I was like a man man that was
a crazy person and and I was only able
to do it because I had to back then I
didn't have the resources to help I need
it and we didn't have the infrastructure
go look at episodes of this show okay
like I said I'm gonna bring this tugboat
to shore but go look it up side of this
show if the search engine worked on
YouTube again I feel like I have to
repeat this say 2015 or 2016 okay every
single sketch was me I had to write them
all I had to play every different
character I had to research every meet
segment and since then sometimes I will
say this I feel like a shell of my
former self and then I have people
around me now who are capable of
shouldering the burden and you know and
they want to shoulder the burden and I
struggle with guilt I hate that about
myself I struggle with guilt sometimes I
think like oh man I should be doing that
I shouldn't be putting quarterblack
Garrett in a sketch all those sketches I
should be doing those because that's
what I used to do I'm giving him too
much I'm giving him too much work and I
don't think you're great at it
you're fantastic at it but because for
so long I had to do it I didn't have the
option of someone like you I've
struggled with this guilt I've struggled
with trying to put myself back into this
pressure cooker because for some reason
it's a I wake up and I'm able to make
things happen but I don't want to be
that it's not a good place to be this
isn't humble bragging it's the kind of
thing that shaves years off your life
and there's no other way for me to turn
on I don't like it about myself
but here's why I'm talking about this I
think this might help someone out there
someone listen well what is it that you
hate about yourself maybe you're
relating to this it's something that's
out of your control and you don't
necessarily know how to go about fixing
it
it starts with information it starts
with the truth
do other people struggle with this have
other people found solutions my goal
here when I do these these crowder
closes segments
it has they've been branded by the team
here I want um we have millions of
listeners and viewers okay millions and
I wake up not feeling exalted by that
fact humbled by it I do not take it
granted for a second I want you guys to
clearly understand that believe me I
don't but I want the millions of people
who will be watching or listening to
this to go out and be better human
beings
I want you all yeah my primary job is to
make you laugh I understand that that's
my lane but if I can't I want you all to
be better fathers I want you all be with
our mothers better husbands better wives
I want you to be better sons daughters
disciples but not a disciple of me I'm a
Christian being a disciple of Christ
that's for me those are the ABCs of me
that's the endgame but if I haven't
served to improve the lives of everyone
who watches or listens to this show and
by proxy improve the lives of everyone
you touch you know I will have failed
and I think an important component to
effecting positive change is identifying
what it is that you just can't stand
about yourself it's just as important as
recognizing your strengths again what is
it in your quiet moments oh I don't know
if you have this I get this when you
can't sleep you're hit it's the pillow
and you actually wince you ever do that
you go can't believe I did that
oh I can't believe I said that
that came out of my mouth I want you to
sit with some quiet time right now pause
it if you have to put on your meditative
music I don't know what it is maybe have
a nap most people have apps get into
your get into your happy place and then
make it very unhappy make it very
unpleasant
what do you despise about yourself can
it be fixed
spoiler alert yeah it can how can it be
fixed
that's what
need to figure out start by finding
other people who struggle with it who
fixed it about themselves ask for help
then create a plan and fix it starts
with recognizing there are things about
yourself that suck that you should hate
me to change told you it would be an
upper see you next week
[Music]